what do you make of conspiracy theories
under this framework of the latter so
here's the thing about conspiracy
theories is that
once in a while they're true right
because sometimes there's a natural
conspiracy actually humans are pretty
good at real conspiracies secret things
uh and then you know I just watched the
Madoff doc
um great new Netflix stock by the way um
and
um so the question is
how do you create a system that is good
at you put the conspiracy theory in and
it either goes eh or it says this is
interesting let's keep exploring it like
how do you put how do you do something
that it can how do you assess and so
again I think the hiron culture
is really good at it because a real
conspiracy what's going to happen is you
put it it's like a little machine you
put in the middle of the table and
everyone starts firing darts at it or
bow and arrow or whatever and everyone
starts kicking it and trying to and
almost all conspiracy theories they
quickly crumble right because they
actually you know you know Trump's
election one is and I actually dug in
and I looked at like every claim that he
or his team made and I was like
all of these don't none of these hold up
to scrutiny none and I was open-minded
but none of them did so that was one
that as soon as it's open to scrutiny it
crumbles
the only way that conspiracy can stick
around in a community is if
it is a culture where that's being
treated as a sacred idea that no one
should kick or throw a dart at because
if you throw a dart it's gonna break so
it's being it's and so what you want is
a is a culture where no idea is sacred
anything can get thrown out and so I
think that then what you'll find is that
9 94 out of 100 conspiracy theories come
in and they fall down the other maybe
four of the others come in and there's
something there but it's not as Extreme
as people say and then maybe one is a
huge deal and it's actually a real
conspiracy well isn't there a lot of
gray area and there's a lot of mystery
isn't that where the conspiracy theories
seep in so uh it's great to hear that
you've really looked into the the the
Trump election fraud claims
but aren't they resting in a lot of kind
of gray area like fog basically saying
that there is dark Forces in the shadows
that are actually controlling everything
I mean the same thing with uh maybe you
can there's like safer conspiracy
theories more less controversial ones
like have we landed on the moon right
the United States ever land on the Moon
there's you know you like the reason
those conspiracy theories work is you
could construct there's incentives and
motivation for faking the moon landing
there's a lot of
um there's a there's very little data
supporting the moon landing
like that's very public and kind of
looks fake space that would be a big
story if it turned out to be fake that's
the r that's that would be the argument
against it like are people really as a
collective going to hold on to a story
that big
um yeah so that but but there's a lot
that the reason they work is there's
mystery yeah it's a great documentary
called behind the curve about flat
earthers and one of the things that you
learn about flat earthers is they
believe
all the conspiracies not just the Flat
Earth they're they're convinced the moon
landing is fake they're convinced 911
was an American con job
they're convinced you know that name a
conspiracy and they believe it and so
it's so interesting is that
I think of it as a um
as a skepticism Spectrum yeah so on one
side you it's like a filter in your head
a filter in your in the beliefs section
of your brain on one end of the spectrum
you are gullible perfectly gullible you
believe anything someone says right on
the other side you're paranoid you think
everyone's lying to you right
everything's everything is false nothing
that anyone says is true right so
obviously those aren't good places to be
um now the healthy place I think that
that the so so I think the healthy place
is to be somewhere in the middle and but
also you can learn to trust certain
sources and then you know you don't have
to do as much apply as much skepticism
to them and so here's what
like when you start having a bias just
so you have a political bias
when your side says something you you
will find yourself moving towards the
gullible side of the spectrum you read
an article written that's that supports
your views you move to the gullible side
of the spectrum and you just believe it
you don't have any where's that
skepticism that you normally have right
and then you move and then you soon as
soon as it's the other person talking
the other team talking you move to the
skeptical the the closer to the to the
in denial paranoid side now
flat earthers are the extreme they are
either at 10 or 1.
so it's like it's so interesting because
they're the people who are saying ah nah
I won't believe you I'm not gullible no
everyone else is gullible about the moon
landing I won't and then yet when
there's this evidence like oh because
you can't see Seattle you can't see the
buildings over that Horizon and you
should which isn't true you should be if
you were or if the Earth around you
wouldn't be able to see them therefore
it's so suddenly they become the most
gullible person here any theory about
the earth flat they believe it it goes
right into their beliefs so they're
actually jumping back and forth between
refuses to believe anything and believe
anything and so they're the extreme
example but I think when it comes to
conspiracy theories the people that get
themselves into trouble are the ones who
they they become really gullible when
they hear a conspiracy theory that kind
of fits with their world view and they
likewise when there's something that's
kind of obviously true and it's not a
big lie they will actually uh they'll
they'll think it is they they just
tighten up their kind of skepticism
filter and and so yeah so I think the
healthy places to be is where you are
not because you also don't want to be
the person who says every conspiracy you
hear the word conspiracy theory and it
sounds like an like a synonym for like
quack job crazy Theory right so yeah so
I I think yeah I think it's be somewhere
in the middle of that spectrum and to
learn to fine tune it which is a tricky
place to operate because you kind of
have to every time you hear a new
conspiracy theory you should approach it
with an open mind
and you know and also if you don't have
enough time to investigate which most
people don't kind of still have a
humility not to make a conclusive
statement that that's nonsense there's a
lot of um social pressure actually yeah
to immediately laugh off any conspiracy
theory if it's done by the the bad guys
right you will quickly get mocked and
laughed at and not taken seriously if
you give any Credence you know back the
lab leak was it was a good one where
it's like uh turned out that that was at
least very credible if not true and
that was a perfect example of one where
when it first came out any not only so
so Brett Weinstein talked about it and
then I in a totally different
conversation said something
complementary about him on a totally
different subject
and people were saying Tim you might
have gone a little off the deep end
you're like quoting someone who is like
a lab leak person so I was getting my
reputation dinged
for complimenting on a different topic
someone whose reputation was totally
sullied because they have you know they
questioned an Orthodoxy right so it's
it's you see in so what what does that
make me want to do
distance myself from Brett Weinstein
that's the at least that's the incentive
that's uh and what does that make other
people want to do don't become the next
Brett Weinstein don't say it out loud
because you don't want to become someone
that no one wants to compliment anymore
right you can see the social pressure
and that's and of course when there is a
conspiracy that social pressure is its
best friend